y a ir lápiz líder del partido centrista
y es a ti que terminó segundo detrás de
la ala derecha del likud de benjamín
netanyahu en las elecciones de marzo en
israel tiene como fecha límite el
miércoles para anunciar un nuevo
gobierno las posibilidades de éxito han
dependido en gran medida del
nacionalista naftalí bennett un ex
ministro de defensa cuyos escaños en el
partido y amina en el creset han sido
suficientes para darle el estatus
decisorio ahora dice que está dispuesto
a intentar ayudar a formar un gobierno
de unidad
uno tiene que tomar responsabilidad en
tiempos tan críticos
por eso pretendo hacer todo lo posible
para crear un gobierno de unidad con mi
amigo ya el rápid juntos sacaremos al
país de la caída implicada en la que
está atrapado y devolveremos a israel su
rumbo de nación y se le mostró lado bajo
un posible acuerdo de poder compartido
bennett se convertiría en el primer
ministro durante dos años reemplazando a
benjamín netanyahu netanyahu lo acusó de
fraude del siglo citando promesas
públicas pasadas en las que dijo que no
se uniría a lápiz y llamó a los miembros
a apoyar a likud
hago un llamado a nuestros amigos que
fueron elegidos por votantes de derecha
hago un llamado a los que tienen
conciencia y un buen camino por delante
sigan por ese camino no creen un
gobierno de izquierdas el gobierno es un
peligro para la seguridad de israel y
para el futuro de israel visto canal
gratuito en ti no quedan muchas
negociaciones para que el lápiz forme un
nuevo gobierno el bloque de partidos
anti netanyahu tiene poco en común
excepto su deseo de poner fin a los 12
años de netanyahu en el poder y evitar
otra elección que sería la quinta en
poco más de dos años
[Música]